[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti
mi vien da sorridere perché di solito
nel mio lavoro sono io che metto altre
persone sul palcoscenico commetto altre
persone davanti alle telecamere oggi che
ci sono qui io effettivamente dico che
non è così semplice
vi racconto un film la storia di un
bambino
questo sono io quando avevo quattro anni
sì avevo i capelli e da bambino avevo
tre sogni semplici diventare un
giocatore nba di pallacanestro diventare
un giocatore di calcio di serie a o
diventare un attore di hollywood tre
sogni comuni che hanno un minimo di
numeri minimo comune denominatore una
grande ambizione però anche tre sogni a
pensarci bene che bambini della mia età
cresciuti negli anni 80 avevano
cresciuti col verona di bagnoli io sono
di verona cresciuti con le prime
immagini e b e in italia cresciuti con
film come t come la storia infinita che
hanno segnato una generazione e da
bambino avevo una grande fantasia una
grande creatività e alla notte sognavo
molto e con pazienza ogni mattina
raccontava mia mamma cosa vedevo sognavo
castelli fantastici paesaggi infiniti
animali selvaggi
una sera durante un sogno
zero sveglia sveglia
io sono danilo gallinari adesso non mi
conosci ma sicuramente in futuro avrà
l'opportunità di conoscermi e volevo
dirti dobbiamo riconoscere il fatto che
non sarai mai un giocatore nba non sarai
sicuramente mai buono come me però avrai
una tua speranza in futuro e soprattutto
il futuro sarà roseo e un giorno capirai
che sono tante cose che ti aspettano
avanti a te gallinari uccideva le mie
ambizioni nba
fin da bambino senza problemi
sarei diventato un grande giocatore di
calcio e avrei vinto la coppa del mondo
con la maglia della nazionale italiana
passa un po di tempo altro sogno ciao
zeno sono alessandro del piero
ora non mi conosci però sono qui per
dirvi una cosa molto importante anche
dure da digerire non diventerai mai è un
calciatore non diventi la banca più del
mondo di calcio è impossibile credimi so
che è dura però poi così è meglio che te
lo dica adesso così ti concetti su altre
cose una cosa positiva è bella tela devo
dire però diventeremo grandi amici e e
diventerai magari un campione del mondo
in un altra attività per cui ci vediamo
presto
ciao i miei due idoli sportivi
uccidevano ogni ambizione sportiva che
avevo quindi con due sogni falliti su
tre ho pensato del terzo fosse troppo
difficile da raggiungere e ho virato su
qualcosa di più sicuro qualcosa che
avevo avrei seguito le orme della mia
famiglia e avrei lavorato nella società
di costruzioni con mio papà che ho
sempre ammirato
era una strada sicura e per questo mi
sono laureato in architettura a firenze
più che della parte progettuale però mi
ha sempre interessato la parte
commerciale del lavoro è finito con gli
studi in italia sono andati in america a
los angeles per imparare come gli
americani spiegavano il marketing come
insegnavano le tecniche di vendita tutte
cose che mi sarebbero servite di lì a
poco nel mio lavoro e nel frattempo
finché ero los angeles mi innamoravo di
questa splendida città e hollywood
iniziava air sarà
vicina anche dal punto di vista
geografico ma la mia vita era su binari
ben precisi lavorare con la mia famiglia
ma siamo all'interno di un film ve l'ho
detto e come in ogni film c'è un colpo
di scena un twist della sceneggiatura
come dicono gli americani
la crisi economica che avanza in italia
toglie ogni ambizione la strada sicura
che c'era prima non c'è più le sicurezze
spariscono e allora mi viene in mente
una frase che mi diceva sempre mio padre
si no ricordati il mio consiglio
cerchione nicchie di mercato e prova ad
essere il migliore nel momento di
massima difficoltà mi sono detto cosa
facile mi arrendo o combatto dovevo
ripartire da zero anzi facendo un gioco
di parole col mio nome ripartire da zero
fai quello che se mi sono detto in tasca
avevo passione ambizione e soprattutto
una grande idea un grande progetto
puntare a hollywood è come una sorta di
all in
mi sono buttato dentro in questo mondo
dove avevo già iniziato a muovermi oggi
dopo 15 anni sono proprietario e
fondatore di una società con sede a
beverly hills che si chiama cangrande il
cui nome ovviamente un omaggio alla mia
verona il mio lavoro consiste nel
condurre in prima persona tutte le
trattative per definire la presenza dei
grandi nomi dello sport della moda del
cinema dello spettacolo ad eventi
televisivi campagne pubblicitarie
produzioni cinematografiche
ero andato in america per imparare a
gestire ea vendere edifici e ad oggi
sono un venditore a tutti gli effetti
vendo talento vendo sogni
vendo persone detta così suona malissimo
infatti vedo le facce ma siamo
all'interno di un film non dimenticatelo
siete voi che dovete distinguere e
finzione e realtà
adesso usciamo dal set vi porto dietro
le quinte del mio lavoro
per farvi vedere e spiegarvi come
funziona una trattativa olio che è un
mondo particolare al mondo a sé stante
con regole tutte sue
in una trattativa
la fase principale è i primi tre minuti
dove non bisogna mai parlare
dell'oggetto di vendita questa una cosa
che mi hanno insegnato gli americani che
ti insegnano a ribaltare i concetti
vedere le cose da un altro lato un'altra
cosa fondamentale è la stretta di mano
conta tantissimo e il vostro biglietto
da visita quindi sguardo fisso negli
occhi sorridete
ripetete il nome della persona che avete
davanti è essenziale
adesso restando sempre in ambito
cinematografico quanti di voi sulle mani
si ricordano fin jerry maguire è
abbastanza ok c'è una scena bellissima
dove cuba gudrun giugno che fa il
giocatore di football americano fa
urlare a tom cruise coprimi di soldi
coprimi di soldi non so se ve le
ricordate
questa è una cosa che possiamo tenere
come base per tutte le cose hollywood
perché se è vero che hollywood tutto si
muove con i soldi e anche vero che ne
hanno abbastanza per dire no a qualsiasi
cosa gli si venga offerto se c'è
qualcosa che non quadra nel contorno
quindi è altro spesso quello su cui io
devo far leva devo guardare con i loro
occhi come una ricerca costante negli
interessi personali perché le volte il
dettaglio fa la differenza
quello che viene proposto in contorno è
più importante di quello che c'è sul
piatto perché a hollywood
io ho una regola che mi tengo sempre in
mente la chiamerà c5 per uno che la
divide in due fasi ricerca e chiusura
mido cinque tentativi per trovare il
talent giusto e un mese di tempo per
chiudere trattative contratto se esco da
questi paletti
so che la situazione non è così
tranquilla perché una delle due parti
vuol dire che non ha urgenza di chiudere
quindi devo essere bravo sempre a
spingere sui tasti giusti perché a
hollywood è come una partita a poker
dove deve essere un chirurgo ai 0
margine di errore non puoi sbagliare
perché altrimenti sei fuori
devi essere bravo ad anticipare le mosse
di chi ti sta di fronte
e come un duello di spada devi sapere
quando affondare il colpo e quando
tirarti indietro perché una fase
essenziale in una trattativa e saper
tenere sempre il coltello dalla parte
del manico in cui è molto difficile
perché sei tu che insegui loro e sei tu
che speri che loro ti ascoltino e tutto
deve essere sempre fatto con la massima
specializzazione e precisione perché è
un lavoro dove la concentrazione deve
essere massima e la professionalità
altissima perché se non conosci le
regole di questo gioco non arrivi al
traguardo è un lavoro che puoi fare da
solo 24 ore al giorno è disponibile
perché ai clienti in tutto il mondo e
deve onorare i loro fusi orari da solo e
perché la tua forza sta nel rapporto di
fiducia che hai con i clienti da una
parte e con gli attori e la gente
dall'altra parte che vogliono che sia tu
che muove i fili vogliono sentire la tua
voce
ne consegue che l'unica è la più forte
forma di vendita qui è il passaparola la
tua reputazione e quella che ti precede
adesso violato cinque punti che possiamo
prendere teoricamente trasferire ogni
trattativa
e invece no perché alla fine l'unica
cosa che conta veramente è l'esperienza
quando si lavora con la soggettività
degli altri
e qui gli altri sono volubili non c'è
una regola fissa non c'è uno schema
predefinito un attore un artista ha un
talento enorme e una sensibilità molto
particolare perché si esprime sotto
varie forme e le richieste che ti fanno
alle volte sono molto particolari
gli americani dicono the devil is in the
di te
il diavolo sta nei dettagli adesso vi
faccio alcuni esempi di dettagli
risultati fondamentali per chiudere dei
contratti questo cane è stato
fondamentale per chiudere un contratto
da 2 milioni di dollari
il cane questo è un cane famoso perché
il suo padrone è molto famoso e dovunque
va al padrone fa il cane e il
trattamento che deve essere riservato a
questo cane è un trattamento 5 stelle
extra lusso perché loro te lo richiedono
ti chiedono 20g giochi scusate 20 giochi
per il cane ti chiedono un letto comodo
per cani ma non 13 perché uno deve
essere messo in albergo uno deve essere
messo nel camerino uno deve essere messo
nel set e ti chiedono un cibo degno di
un tre stelle michelin
questo è un cotte che si chiama
pennicillina quanti voi tigri del sabato
sera lo conoscono vediamo adesso mi
voglio vedere nessuno è una cosa a 1
un eroe questo è un cocktail preferito
da un famoso attore firmo questo attore
dopo un minuto di tempo ma arriva questa
mail titolo eni chillin cocktail sotto
la ricetta telefono dico faccio un
controllo perché sono educato li chiamò
e gli dico guardate è arrivata questa
email penicillina cocktail credo che sia
per il vostro barista che stanno
organizzando la serata mia risposta no e
cocktail preferito dall'attore devi dire
il tuo cliente di predisporre un barista
24 ore su 24 disponibili pronta a
preparare la in tre giorni
preso una volta c'era lì il barista sei
valige piene di scarpe richiesta che mi
viene fatta da un artista donna vedo
uomini che scuotono la testa e dicono sì
anche mia moglie me la fai non è un
artista erano 100 paia di scarpe per due
giorni di campagna pubblicitaria se
l'artista fosse stata svegliata che ho
fatto i conti 24 ore avrebbe potuto
cambiarsi un paio di scarpe ogni 33
minuti
pensate la faccia il cliente quando gli
sono andato a dire che doveva pagare
decine di migliaia di euro per
trasportare queste valigie però senza
felice non arrivava l'artista e questi
sono dettagli di un mondo particolare
dove la forza e la creatività a los
angeles c'è una luce particolare sarà la
temperatura è 20 25 gradi tutto l'anno
distingue l'estate e l'inverno a seconda
di quando tramonta il sole ma hollywood
e los angeles hai la sensazione di voler
poi fare qualcosa di poter fare qualcosa
e hollywood è un microcosmo dove entra
il meglio del meglio dove livello
intellettuale delle persone altissimo
dove ti giudicano per quello che è in
testa non per quello che appare e dove
un continuo sgorgare di idee e sei
sicuro che l'idea che sta uscendo in
questo momento è migliore di quella
precedente ma la forza di questo sistema
che vive su un estraeva la competitività
è il suo tempo anche la sua debolezza
perché è una centrifuga che ti prende ti
travolge hollywood ogni giorno è una
battaglia in nulla è sicuro neanche per
gli attori perché tutti i lavori sono
instabili e se c'è una cosa che capisci
subito che da fuori sembra un mondo è
enorme
in realtà alla fine
un microcosmo e le élite e una punta
della piramide dove tutti si conoscono
ma se sbagli sei fuori perché alla fine
quello che conta è quello che tu porti
io oggi vivo a beverly hills e con
hollywood ci lavoro ogni giorno e se
dovessi scrivere una lettera se dovessi
parlare al bambino a 0 pisani
gli direi di stare tranquillo che alla
fine tutto si realizzerà anche se
diciamo in maniera diversa gli direi di
stare tranquillo di credere in se stesso
perché la passione è quello che conta
l'amore nelle cose che si fanno anche se
l'amore costa superficie ed è vero per
fortuna non sono io a recitare su un
palco che se no la tensione mi
distruggerebbe ma non ci sono io nei
film non sono diventato un attore non ci
sono io nelle campagne pubblicitarie ma
sapere che quell artista è lì perché io
ho contribuito a fare qualcosa è perché
c'era un bambino che sognava mi rende
veramente orgoglioso come dicono gli
americani shoot for the moon even if you
miss you will and the stuff punta sempre
alla luna anche se la mancherai comunque
terry tra le stelle a oggi grazie
[Applauso]
a oggi sonia ancora molto la notte come
da bambino
solo che al posto di raccontare i sogni
a mia mamma oggi le racconta mia moglie
ci siamo
c'è stata un'evoluzione pochi giorni fa
durante un sogno c'era un re chi mangia
è questa
e questa è la fine del mio film grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]